taxation from the left its seen is this
wonderful just this incredibly effective
behavioral engineering method right well
let's tax cigarettes because we want to
discourage cigarettes let's tax L Club
because one are scared alcohol okay
apply that Chuck income here's my
question of the day at what point does
someone become so wealthy that it's
immoral in your opinion because Cortez
Cortez has decided what it is ish I
guess I don't know your amount is what's
that number and I won't have that
retirement number what's the number to
you where all of a sudden becomes an
immorality as it relates to wealth but
here we go
we're gonna be addressing this very
popular apparently dead tax but I don't
know if we call it a tax plan but Cortez
here to say do we live in a more well
that allows for billionaires is that a
moral outcome
huh well you know what's funny is
because every time people ask Cortez how
she's going to pay for her socialist
programs her answer is billionaires will
pay for them this is what's so
remarkable like a suggestion by the way
I think we actually have another clip
one of the most popular is a 70 percent
tax rate and everyone who makes more
than 10 million dollarsí but it's not
that bad it's only 70 percent after
every 10 million you make let's hear her
talent but once you get to like the
tippy tops on your 10 millionth dollar
rates is 60 or 70 percent it doesn't
mean all 10 million dollars are taxed at
an extremely high rate but it means that
as you climb up this ladder you should
be contributing more because you were
contributing so less before you reach
the ten million dollar mark Arnold thank
you by the way this just shows the
stupidity and I will say if you'll say
well don't talk down there's no the
stupidity of the cortes base that she
has to explain the mere concept of
marginal tax rates like so if I make
generally I'm gonna pay half so it'd
rather just make nine million this is so
ridiculous the fact that people who
follow her don't understand what
marginal tax rates are now hold on you
give me that light gel she's wishing
that by the way that the super-rich
didn't even exist her answer to
everything is well just gonna tax the
billionaires they're gonna pay for it
how you gonna pay for college tax the
billionaire's your favorite ones health
care tax the billionaires and here's
something it's so funny to me before we
get into statistics just what we're
talking about the morality of this issue
even though Cortes and and don't say you
the followers out there who stumble
across this channel drunken after a
stuffed burger the night before even
though you claim that the concept of
billionaires is is immoral only your
system requires the existence of
billionaires to exist the capitalist
system does not the free enterprise
system is financially blind yours
requires the great immoralities of
billionaire ISM don't know if that's a
term I don't get to be a reality as the
foundation of your system in the first
place we don't mean it you make what you
make you get taxed a fair amount you
require billionaires for it to work even
though you think that it couldn't
possibly be less moral how is nobody
talking about this let's move on to our
next claim I think that it's wrong that
that a vast majority of the country does
not make a living rate wage I think it's
very important just a living wind should
how we're now we're gonna continue
your kids foreshadowing it's wrong that
that corporations like Walmart can and
in Amazon can get pay they can get paid
by the government essentially experience
a wealth transfer from the public for
paying people less than a minimum wage
did you see what you just did that did
you see what she said living wage and
minimum wage and though they were
interchangeable by the way as far as the
rest of the bull do we really even need
to fact-check this Washington Post gave
her Pinocchio's saying that the vast
majority and not only it's not the vast
majority even up 32 to 38 percent of
American workers who make below living a
living wage and that's according to an
abstracts in it it's not uniform across
the board by the way this is the same
Washington Post that fact-check Donald
Trump's claim that burgers were stacked
a mile high at the White House dinner
saying that one of right-wing conspiracy
theory fake news by the way even they go
dance come on you're killing us here
really it makes it makes me less
empathetic to poor people you know why
cuz keep in mind not making a living
wage and the ID says doesn't it you're
starving in a bamboo hut do you know
what the latest iPhone let's move on to
the next claim that that that she makes
her she makes them to the government
pays Amazon and Walmart that goes back
to the rally for Bernie with Jean get
well marked and the island came in like
this is nothing new
by the way how do you know it's not true
because it's still legal it's illegal to
pay less than the minimum wage wait for
a second Amazon actually suppose they
pay people $15 an hour your buddy Bernie
praise them for this Jeff Bezos an evil
filthy rich shut up a [ __ ] only pays 15
an hour I retract my statement
temporarily to the car guys your floor
no she just continually uses minimum
wage living wage interchangeably it's
like it's just so remarkable to me that
people allow this to go unchecked look
the places I was just running now this
yeah
without ever even a line for the
possibility of some accuracy in fact a
living wage minimum wage just say it's
like a quitting murder with Boppity
pooping someone on the head wait wait a
sec wait was it murder there was a bomb
wasn't murder
it wasn't is it a minimum wage it's a
living wage what does that mean we know
a good wage went okay but are we talking
about a minimum wage now it's a living
way by the way the rich are getting
richer you know who else is also getting
richer the middle class and the poor
they're getting richer that's something
that always family go all the
billionaires you're getting wealthier
than they were in the past
so are the middle class and the poor
yeah but the richer but the rich are
getting even are getting more richer
really you envious prick how about being
grateful for what you have how about
starting with that speaking of being
grateful we're grateful when you
subscribe but more importantly you get
the notification bell here on YouTube
because subscriptions just disappear in
your box hit that Bell join my club nine
dollars annually 69 for students
veterans active military and subscribe
on iTunes in case we ever get D platform
let's move on to something else that
Cortez has to say are we comfortable
with a society where someone can
have a personal helipad while this
citizens experiencing what is rates of
people's Oscars in homelessness and
since the Great Depression sure those
two things coexist at the same time how
are those two things how are those two
things connected at all by the way no
let me answer this for you if you were
like a serial killer with threads going
across the room when the number
twenty-three helipads
and you would end up nowhere you'd end
up outside of your sex dungeon where the
cops would find you and say this you
made it real easy it's almost as though
your connections we're nonsensical mr.
Bundy okay let's try and draw let's
let's look at it through Lonnie let's
look at California a lot of people say
it's not fair to point to Venezuela even
though you endorsed that [ __ ] let's go
to California since it's stateside
really interesting facts about
California I always talk about this has
the most far left policies of any state
arguably you know it's not arguable they
have more billionaires than any other
state and it's also the number one state
for poverty hmm the dots on the back of
your kids menu map dummy no one else did
that connect the Dobson kids menu
Malcolm they thought I was a [ __ ] when
I was a kid I did the little connect the
dots in the maze faster than anyone they
say history daddy's really bored he's
kind of a dick your son in contrast by
the way do we really need to reiterate
that it's it's been shown time and time
again statistically the capitalism free
enterprise pulls millions of people out
of poverty more than any other system
since the beginning of time by the way
well you were gonna say something well
no this it's something has been
bothering other Zemeckis when she brings
up Amazon and the homeless and a
baseless getting it a big tax cut tax
break the day that the tax break was
announced and she says well my
constituents are blown at my phone lines
the week before they reelected the exact
same governor who's giving him the tax
break while ignoring the subways falling
apart because he's an orange man band
yeah good for you the year before that
they were they in record numbers voted
for the mayor who's been ignoring the
homeless and the subways so if these ass
clowns are complaining about this now
the line to kiss me as forms to the
right
why are we complaining about this how
most people in the subways are just
Subway restaurants because they fall out
of fashion since you know the whole
pedophile
hold it Carl does next clip maybe this
idea of idealizing this outcome of maybe
one day you too can be a billionaire and
own more than millions of families
combined is not in an operational or
good thing why not okay it's not a
zero-sum game
people like contests think the only way
that you can make a billion despite just
taking it from other people
yes how it works poor people don't have
a billion dollars you look at people
like Jeff Bell you look at Bill Gates
they they employ thousands upon
thousands of people what this does it
doesn't just appear out of the sky it's
not the way she's talking about record
homelessness what's funny she's in New
York City you guys have had what you
wanted for years it'd be like really
pointing to Detroiters oh it's this
bastion of republicanism like well if
you look at Detroit and you see what
Republicans got what they wanted
completely unfettered since 61 you
couldn't be further from the truth
Cortes you couldn't be less rooted in
reality here's something that really
bothers me what did it just become okay
to vilify business owners period that's
a business that's remarkably talk about
others and we talk about different
classes of people and I you should never
sort of have this deep personalization
that that happens with minorities okay
but why is it okay to do it to business
owners just because they happen to
contribute by the way why is it immoral
for a business owner I've never
understood this please someone let me
know this has always been lost on me why
is it immoral for a business owner to
sign the front of a check over to an
employee but not for someone like
Cortese to sign the back of a check
receiving it even though she's provided
no value of her own well here's one
thing too we talked about the immorality
of money in billion but what's the real
number Elizabeth Warren doesn't agree
with Cortes doesn't agree with Bernie
none of them actually agree in the
number as far as what the moral amount
of money is to have that's why they have
to vilify business owners because they
know that as a general rule business
owners who at this point are successful
enough to tax oh they can be vilified
because they have more on average than
the average bear that's what that's why
they can't give you a specific number
and they just say well it's business
owners bad you know how I can tell you
that it's immoral to implement cortezes
LAN asked me Brautigan how do I know
that it's immoral that's why can I put a
fine you could be just as immoral if she
walked in right now and took half of
this studio equipment and walked right
out genuine we heard this about Bernie
and Cortez leashes just genuine about
what did anyone about wanting to steal
people's stuff what if it would have
been a friend who is honest I'm gonna
steal that O'Henry bar well do you know
what he's a felon but at least he's
honest who cares
and there's one thing I know it's gonna
sound selfish ort of self gratifying I
am a business owner right and I don't
know when it happened that all of a
sudden two people like Cortez I just
woke up and I'm a dick for no reason I
don't know when that happen because it's
a slow progression of a pride swallowing
seats that I will never fully tell you
about where you know this I took no
money bankrolled it out of a savings
account yep by the way let's go with
this what do you wake up when do you
clock into work because for the last
five years before this year and you know
that now I'm gonna be taking some time
gonna be trying to get my health in
order for at least five years I woke up
and was actually working a minimum of
four hours before the average American
citizen walks into the office 5:00 a.m.
every single morning working add that up
for five years what's that worth to you
let alone the stress I have people I
heard one person in this now this
comment section saying yeah the richest
man cuz we're coming for that cheddar
cheddar your code for Brautigan cheddar
you're coming from quarterback Garrett's
cheddar you're coming for Abbey's Henry
coming from a t-shirt you're not coming
from my cheddar
you're coming for cheddar that has been
doled out to other people through
commerce and unlike the rumors up no no
listen this is it loud ORS Crowder is a
business entirely independent which is
funded by three things your
contributions advertising and licensing
agreements don't work for the blaze have
never worked for someone else this is an
independent company where we have
partnerships to try and give you more
value at it but for some reason this is
something that's vilified as opposed to
those who suckle at the government's tea
by the way this is something that no one
has ever been able to explain to me
taxation from the left at Cena's is
wonderful just this
the effective behavioral engineering
method right well let's tack cigarettes
because we want to discourage cigarettes
let's tack sell clubs wanted to skirt
alcohol let's text guns make them more
expensive in California have the
extortion tax in California and the
bullet button let's tax big gulps while
we're at it okay apply that check income
why does this thing why it's just
completely lost on people what do you
think is going to happen with someone
who wakes up works five hours before
anybody else even steps foot even
darkens the threshold of that door for
five 10 15 years see it sees her company
go into the red pays other people thinks
about their every night before they go
to sleep and so first thing they think
about when they wake up because they
have to pay employees even though
they're not taking money for themselves
they happen to despite statistical
realities having taken this risk and
rolled the dice find themselves with
some modicum of success only to have you
step in and say now we're gonna take 70%
what happens they will leave just like
any kind of man who you would want to
keep court - I need onion a cigar hey
you like this video subscribe or click
one of these videos playing in a box you
know what hit the notification bail
because subscriptions don't really mean
anything anymore especially if you're
not 18 or older at the very least logged
in to YouTube is 18 or older because
sometimes people are 25 but they don't
know how to use the YouTube system
properly and then you never just get the
notification pal or you hate yourself